emigrant Mexican what is that it the
first word I think about when I hear the
word immigrant is the word empathy
because I feel that that's the only
thing that we need when dealing with
issues of immigration in our country the
first thing that comes to mind is
someone foreign not necessarily so
somebody that you know
just like you it's just they come from a
different place the one word I think of
when I hear the word immigrant it's
sadness because immigrants are people
who want to leave their country to find
a better life I could never leave my
country when I say the word immigrant
first thing that comes to mind is
illegal immigrant it's a definitely
negative negative meaning to the word
immigrant the first thing that comes to
mind right now is there was a
nationalization ceremony in the
courthouse that I am currently facing
and I think of a lot of people who maybe
speak English as a second language a
heck of a lot better than I speak
whatever language they speak is the
first language or as the second language
American I think of somebody who is not
American I think hard-working actually
for example I think Mexicans are some of
the hardest-working people here Mexican
I think of Americans because Americans
are a people composed of different
ethnicities different cultures from all
walks of life that all have come to this
land on one piece of the same land
shared by the entire world so this is a
good representation of the entire earth
if you really think about it there's a
whole lot of noise out there about
immigration